hello everyone this is cristalia and if
you're hearing this message
you're not currently enjoying
congratulations as it's supposed to be
heard
if you'd like to
go on over to chris oops go on over to
patreon.com crystalia
and that's where you can hear uncut
episodes and extra episodes along with
other segments
like one i do called review mode and
also other episodes of with chris the
popular youtube
show that i do on youtube
anyway
let's get down to it
hi guys
it's crystalia
and welcome to my podcast
congratulations crazy
crazy
[Music]
what's up you guys how's everybody doing
you know it's all good dude everything's
great man uh we're having a good time
doing it all you know it's uh what can i
say man i haven't worked out honestly
for three weeks i took a little trip i
haven't worked out for three weeks and
guess what still look fantastic i'm
sorry to break your heart strong guys
yeah
i'm sorry break your heart strong guys i
do lots of lots of heavy lifting and
sometimes i take some time off and it's
starting to break your heart strong as
i'm gonna start again tomorrow sorry to
break your heart strong guys
anyway dude this is another episode of
congratulations and we're loving it um
one fire just gave me a weird look
wonder if everything's okay it's still
gonna be trucking forward all good dude
everything's great we're gonna just keep
it going um
do you know do you know about busy bone
the the [ __ ]
and the bone thugs in harmony do it
first of all worst name of a rap group
ever bone thugs and harmony
and i loved how there were like four of
them and then all of a sudden there were
[Music]
950 of them
like they were so successful it was such
a moment in rap history the bone talks
everybody
every day every day every day every day
see you at the crossroads you won't be
lonely see you at the crossroads so you
won't be alone
got it put them dipper body and now
so bad
could only be popular in 99
eeked out the [ __ ] millennium with
[ __ ] ads on
busy bone lazy bone [ __ ] grumpy bone
you know
oh man
grumpy bone sounds like marriage sex
awesome
um but yeah dude
oh all right
grumpy bone
all right
um
[Laughter]
all right
son
um
and then there were there was that one
[ __ ] that was like you know what
they're actually really saying if you
slow it down and you're just like dude
shut the [ __ ] up i have i have english
homework
i got [ __ ] to do dude i'm gonna go
outside and throw sticks around
you're gonna tell me if i slow down the
[ __ ] bone thugs in the busy bo
and one time and busy bone is out to
lunch now dude
for real
he is one and i knew it too this is when
i knew
i met i met busybone once i was at the
comedy store this was years ago
and i was talking to somebody on the
patio the comedy store and busy bone
well actually i don't even see him i
hear him first i hear from the
background part of my [ __ ]
interruption part of my [ __ ]
interruption pardon my [ __ ]
interruption that's what i hear and i
look over and it's busy bone just
talking at me and whoever i'm talking to
pardon my [ __ ] interruption
pardon my [ __ ] said it so much
said it no [ __ ] i think he said it
15 times pardon my [ __ ]
interruption dude and we were both like
hey man you're interrupting yourself now
mr bone
and then he just and then we're looking
at him like uh yeah and he just walks in
between us and keeps walking dude oh
dude
it's on
my [ __ ] interruption that's
what he did dude and it was so funny and
sad
and sad because it was 2013 and where
have you been
busy but why they're calling busybond
well he's busy [ __ ] interrupting
people over and over again that's for
sure
i see you at the crossroads see you at
the crossroads
and i'm going to miss everybody i know
and some giving up a child of good news
if god's got it and i'm gonna miss
everybody and now
that's [ __ ] beautiful
no warm-up
[Music]
oh then my [ __ ] interruption
he just wrapped it and scooted in
between us dude and i was like what an
[ __ ]
have you seen him do interviews dude
dude there's interviews where he has
like a [ __ ] raiden hat on and he's
sitting back and he's just and as their
as
he got interviewed with one of the other
bones you know lazy bone or [ __ ] hip
bone or some [ __ ]
and [ __ ]
and he was just sitting there and and
and the other bone was talking a lot
about how bone thugs and harmony was the
[ __ ] and then [ __ ] busy and then busy
bone when when they asked busy bone a
question busy bone took his hat up and
just stared at him and was like well you
know how it was what's this he's just
insane dude he just leaned forward and
then after he was done talking he'd lean
back and put his hat back over his eyes
like he thinks he's [ __ ] dr claw or
some [ __ ]
but this was the [ __ ] my buddy sent me
this this clip
hollywood underground
this is from hollywood underground all
right let's go here we go all right dude
you know what it is
hey
backstage you made that make sense but
when you call on the illuminaries
i already know it's headed downhill when
you start with a sentence when you call
on the illuminaries
okay and dude he's pointing so much and
you know that he just knows he's right
whether he's right or not you know you
know he knows he's right
so you just sit back and you relax
when somebody says something and they
say
something about illuminaries you sit
back you got no you don't say whoa hold
on a second what's an illuminati you
don't do any what kind of illuminary do
you mean no you don't do that you sit
back and you relax and you realize he's
gonna skip the part where he says paul
did my [ __ ] interruption right
but he's growing because this is this
happened after he did this to me so he's
backstage and there's a [ __ ] hanger
on next to him that's just yes ending
him right this is why they said don't
speak on the illuminati
not only is it jesus's family but it's
also your family no i see the light
that's guiding everybody
is like a bad light sucked on helium but
when you have a good life all you have
to do is call on the illuminaries and
click the channel it's going to talk to
you about mrs arnold
it's going to talk to you about your
school it's going to talk to you and
tell you where you're going to be at the
end three important things mrs arnold
your school and where you're gonna be
the illuminati's is gonna call you
and tell you about three things arnold
miss arnold the school
and
where you're gonna be there's can slip
around the earth seven times in one
second oh
then the illuminati wait wait wait wait
wait let's go back to the end of the day
see luminaries can slip around the earth
seven times in one second
then the illuminati's if anything is
sitting on the earth they can claim they
sell then
they are human threw up in his mouth
threw up in his mouth right there caught
don't understand because they never been
with christ
oh
that's what the count don't understand
because they never been with christ
threw up in his mouth three times
already
you bring christ to your cult anything
you kill shall die for eternity
and that's what people don't understand
that's why christ came and became dead
so they know if there's something you
think is the lord bring christ to your
[ __ ] core [ __ ]
when when people talk and they start
doing this and they're just like just so
you know you're like oh [ __ ] step away
dude because they're a [ __ ] second
away from just
unloading on you with the with their
hands you know what i mean
threw up in his mouth three times when
he did this bring him to your core [ __ ]
and that will show you [ __ ] that [ __ ]
had died forever [ __ ]
imagine the cameraman dude right in his
face and the cameraman just like this
okay okay sure bring bring christ to
your core right right bring christ to
your car the eliminators go around the
world seven times in a second okay sure
we get down [ __ ] the temple of
[ __ ] christ you better trust
and believe oh my purple homie
uh
what
oh my purple homie
what is he a california raisin
he keep a turban on
paris saying 300 pairs saying stop how
you doing
and that's the way that we rock and we
rolling and that's a blessing cause he
could have killed me from there but he
said nowhere i'm gonna love that brother
and he understand where i'm coming from
because of the thunk patterns you're
talking to a brother without a brain
that brother has a thought like a
lightning
brother without a brain i'm following
you now also dude
how is nobody it's actually sad like
nobody's around this guy being like
i guess turn the camera off when he
starts talking about illuminaries and
how they slip around the world uh seven
times in a second
let's just
maybe ask somebody else a question at
this point
like everyone just like literally the
chick in the back is like
yep illuminaries
a lightning bolt a burning [ __ ]
lee terevino with a golf club with iron
in his goddamn hand that's why he don't
like metal like that famous thing my bad
my bad oh
dizzy bone this is the way the [ __ ] that
we get down without any [ __ ] if i
put my hand out there all i'm gonna say
is which one you want to be
that's my dad
oh my you know
if i put my hand out there all i'm gonna
say is which one you want to be
how much i mean that's like a [ __ ]
literally that he's he in real life is
the guy that a nicholas cage character
has to go to and talk to in one scene to
try and figure out where the [ __ ] gem
is you know what i mean
[Laughter]
it's just like [ __ ] [ __ ] where's the
gem
wha
at the end of the day see a luminaries
can slip around the earth seven times in
one second and [ __ ] could just like
fall
just insane dude pardon my [ __ ]
interruption dude
bone thugs you know
wow
they're all like 60 now and [ __ ]
bro i went on a trip um
we went on a trip me and the family
calvin took his first
uh
plane ride and we didn't know what to do
we didn't know rather we didn't know if
it was how it was going to go is what i
is what i mean to say so we got him we
took a trip to saint louis and we took a
trip to north carolina uh and we took a
flight to saint louis and then our
flight to north carolina and then a
flight back we were there for 11 days
now is it too long yes did i say i'll do
it because i didn't want to have an
argument yes dude did she want to even
make it longer yes but did i get out of
making it longer yes so 11 days was
where we [ __ ] pretty much uh what do
you call it made a compromise even
though i didn't even bring it up at all
yes i know it was a christmas even still
yes dude
even though i didn't even bring it up
was it still a compromise in my head yes
did i hold it over my head in the whole
trip and sometimes start arguing yes
i've been working on it yes does it
matter no because we still got the
arguments but it's all good
okay
it's all
good did she want to go for two weeks
yes did she mention it briefly and i
said let's just go for maybe 10 days and
she said
she didn't really want to but ended up
saying okay hey yes
was that still too long did i only want
to go for about maybe six or seven days
a yes dude did we end up going for 11
days a year did we take too many flights
yes
did i hold it over my did i hold
overhead the whole time yes dude
this is yes
is it all good maybe
so um
so anyway we [ __ ] did we we went we
took him on the dude i didn't know what
to expect with calvin and we just she
she got so much [ __ ] she's the best mom
dude she got so much [ __ ] she got like
coloring books [ __ ] uh just cotton
for him to throw around a box of 50 toys
that are like these little bitch-ass
toys cost like two dollars and we just
got like a box of a bunch of toys it was
like a slinky and we were like we don't
know what to do we got him a [ __ ] hat
with a propeller on it just all sorts of
[ __ ] prescription glasses just anything
you know what i mean
because they get she's like i gotta i
saw on youtube mom said to get this it
was like everything i was like why the
prescription glasses she was like well
you know he tried to figure it out why
shit's blurry and it [ __ ] buys us 10
minutes we're like all right cool at
least he won't be crying
he never cries anyway but so we took him
to the [ __ ] on the dude it's so cute
see him
it's so cute seeing him on the [ __ ]
plane dude
we put headphones on him and he was just
watching he was like why does the sound
sound why does it sound like it's inside
my head
why does this show sound like it's
inside my head
just watching [ __ ]
and they're just like the [ __ ] hawk
goes fly fly
and he's just like whoa
the hawk goes the polar bear digs out
the ice
and he's just like whoa
with a big with a big ass headphones
with an extra [ __ ] thing that tight
knits over it he looked like a [ __ ]
one of those aliens in mars attacks
it's just like
and the zebra runs away from the tiger
or it gets gutted
whoa that's crazy
mama birds
feed their young
gross [ __ ] regurgitated worms
what the [ __ ] am i watching
you know flies only live
days that's if they avoid a [ __ ] fly
swatter inside
then the last thing that goes through
its head is its [ __ ] anus what the
[ __ ]
where am i watching
oh it's for kids just because their eyes
are wide
don't get sucked in
by satan what
no their eyes are wide it's fine i swear
to god some of these children books
they're just like and then grandma went
straight to hell
what the [ __ ] and then some kids just
eyes are wide and the grandma's eyes are
wide and jesus and the devil's eyes are
white they're their eyes are wide it's
fine one has a beak it's a it's an ally
it's it's it's a [ __ ] animal it's
fine
uh
so yeah so we took them and it was cute
as [ __ ] dude
flight delayed [ __ ] yes
waiting at the airport way too long
calvin's sitting there just
looking around oh look that's jersey
mike's cool
oh look that starbucks nice what's that
a gate cool some plants inside nice
hey look hudson news what the [ __ ] is
that even i don't know son
why can't you get a [ __ ] magazine and
also a ceramic eagle in it
i don't know maybe some people like
ceramic eagles when they start when they
when they want to [ __ ] travel
so
we're waiting and we get on the plane
finally and we take off and we take off
and it's we take off
in calvin's bedtime so we're like we're
we're [ __ ] we're just gonna
we're gonna be it's gonna be fine we're
just gonna deal with it we're gonna get
in at [ __ ] oh dark 30 and it's gonna
be fine we're just gonna put him to bed
dude that kid [ __ ] giggled the whole
flight we're like let's go to bed come
on lay down and he would just go
and then he'd get back up and go
[Laughter]
i was like dude are you just a [ __ ]
drunk
it was unbelievable
and the [ __ ] ipad was going
hopefully the plane doesn't take a
nosedive
what the [ __ ] it's okay the pilot's eyes
are wide
and he just [ __ ] would go to bed go
see peace we said go seepies and he
would just go lay on the [ __ ] middle
seat and then just be like
dude n didn't cry once got
okay
landed
at 12 12.05
kristen set up the rental car yay she
set up the rental car yay because we're
going to need to drive around and see
her friends and everything in her family
yay she set up the rent to buy the
rental car yeah so it's gonna be all
good
so we went with calvin and i'm carrying
them dude [ __ ] gets heavy after
a while i mean what is he like 26 pounds
but dude these biceps are yeah sure
they're crazy nice but dude after a
while i need more oxygen you know
so we're out there waiting for the
[ __ ] enterprise
shuttle to come
waiting and waiting and waiting and
waiting 20 minutes goes by where the
[ __ ] is the [ __ ] enterprise shuttle
now you know me
i'm cool but when i got a weight
blood starts coming out mayness
calvin's just chilling on my [ __ ]
shoulder just like this attack pack
every [ __ ] car that goes by attack
truck tuck truck pack tuck yup say the r
in it next time but it's all good tack
tack
that's car and tuck that's truck he can
distinguish barely and he [ __ ] can
almost do the different you know [ __ ]
and croc
that's the difference it's really hard
to tell about i'm his dad so i know what
he said yes that's right yes where the
[ __ ] is this enterprise [ __ ]
so i say babe while i'm holding him
exhausting my [ __ ] limbs do you mind
um checking the website or something or
getting a phone call because i don't
know where this [ __ ] enterprise
shuttle is
and she looks on the [ __ ] website
calls
[Music]
four rings that's too many for a
business
pick up
five
six why hold on that's too many for a
business
pick up
[Music]
eight
but business
you're a business
half a night
you've reached enterprise and but you
don't sound like this is in person and
why would that be because you're an
establishment and i got a car from you
what time is it babe she says 11 30 and
i say well when's the shuttle coming so
now i'm looking it up and i call because
when i call shit's gonna go
bonk and i want to explode i'm high
who can
with my kid just who can i blame
who's around
who's the right
who's looking who who wants to make eye
contact don't blame you i'll blame
whoever the [ __ ] who wants to make eye
contact what's up
whoever's getting look at me you want
where's the car
sir i don't i i'm i'm just from i'm a
local okay well where's my car
where's the shuttle ma'am
i'm just a grandma well you made eye
contact with me didn't you
so
i'm like well what do we do they're not
picking up and then we read in the fine
print in the fine print
it closes at 12. yay
closes at 12 yay closes to 12 yay so i
say well babe surely check your email
because this is your fault because you
have an email
telling us if our flight is delayed that
we weren't going to be able to do it we
needed to make other plans and she
checked her email and they didn't have
it
so they didn't send us an email so hey
enterprise go [ __ ] yourself
go [ __ ] yourself enterprise
you left me
and my [ __ ]
fiancee and my little homie stranded at
the st louis airport and i don't know if
you know anything about saint louis but
it's not [ __ ] nice
bullet wise
it's not nice bullet wise
okay when it comes to bullets whizzing
by your head
saint louis
gets a one
all right
so i'm exhausted my oxygen from my
[ __ ] crazy lumped up bicep
still calling enterprise like they're
gonna [ __ ] get in at 12 45 a.m
so i said well what the [ __ ] do we do we
don't have uh we don't we we're here at
the st louis airport if it was just me
and you
we could get an uber but the kids
[ __ ] one and a half
so what the [ __ ] do we do
you can't sit in the [ __ ] back of a
subaru
with no seat
so we sit there and wait we're the only
people in the airport there's one guy
who's like got a uniform on some uniform
it didn't even have to do with the
airport but he was like yeah you know
[ __ ] it i'll wear any uniform and just
point people in certain directions if
they say anything to me
and then we're like certain he was just
sitting on like something that you're
not even you know they have the airports
have those [ __ ] posts for no reason
like they just looked like big dildos
coming out of the ground he was just
[ __ ] straight up sitting on one like
it was going in his anus
and i was like sir do you know where and
he was like yeah over there or whatever
i don't know what i asked i don't
remember because i was [ __ ] blood
curdling mad
so i was like well we gotta get an uber
and she was like what about him and i'm
like i don't know it's [ __ ] dangerous
to [ __ ] but what the [ __ ] else we're
gonna do sleep at the saint louis
airport and wait till enterprise opens
so she's like i guess so we'll just hold
his [ __ ] seatbelt so we called up we
got an uber and uber came and the guy
that guy
shows up and he was like hey what's up
and i was like hey yeah how long is it
to the hotel and he's like 20 minutes
and i was like oh okay cool and he saw
me with the kid he's like do you have a
car seat and i was like i was like here
we go
[ __ ] with utter comp just play this
out with utter confidence so i looked
right in his eyes and i said no and he
said oh [ __ ] um how old is he
and i said
four
my son
can't take two steps without falling on
his chin
my son
says
no words
he says tuck for truck
he's not four
but he the guy just goes like the guy
goes like this how you knew we were in
st louis the guy goes like this
all right
he's wearing diapers obviously oh and it
has
[ __ ] in it you can smell it
we put him in between us in the back
seat of the [ __ ] suburban
dude
we're just like just give him the ipad
because if he cries he's gonna know he's
not four right
[ __ ] just give him the ipad so give
him the ipad it's like shouldn't be
in the back here without a car seat it's
okay the uber driver's got wide eyes
and he's just sitting there stinks like
[ __ ] just [ __ ] probably three times
since we've been [ __ ] stranded
and we get to the hotel dude and you
know me i'm pissed and [ __ ] chris
even kristen's [ __ ] upset at this
point because she's like jesus [ __ ]
enterprise dude and even my son he
doesn't even give a [ __ ] we're like i'm
like are you will you be pissed too and
he's just a [ __ ] diaper full of [ __ ]
just like
he didn't give a [ __ ] dude this kid's an
angel dude
and so we get to the [ __ ] and i want
to say this
the union station hotel in saint louis
we show up
at
15.
nobody
what's that [ __ ] keith sweat
nobody who was there keith sweat hit it
nobody
zero people were there
hey but hey but building
you're a hotel
all you have are people inside you dude
i didn't even [ __ ] even in the rooms
there was
nobody
sweat hit it he slides in nobody but
it's just as close cause even he's not
there
we walk in with all the bags
i don't know if you know
but when you take a trip for 11 days
with a family
you're not carrying around two totes and
an ice machine
you can around
nine bags the size of the city you're in
so
i [ __ ] shh
i got the three but i oh i think i also
got a kid you know i got a kid i got two
bags and another bag on that she's got a
bag and another bag on that we get the
[ __ ] we bought at [ __ ] hudson news
and a doll for [ __ ] calvin and we sho
and we're like hey we're like [ __ ]
can we is there excuse me throwing rocks
at [ __ ] uh people's windows can you
like we're the boyfriend of whoever's
inside the [ __ ] st
the [ __ ] hotel
hey i get parents home
i'm like baby let's just go come on and
then finally somebody comes out really
old dude and he's like hey um what's up
and i'm like hey dude thank god you're
here
can we get
these bags up to our room and so we can
check in and the guy says oh
i [ __ ] you not the guy says
we don't normally do that
and in my head i'm screaming
hey but bellhop
you're a bell hop
huh when i go ding you hop over here
there was no bell
and you were sauntering
so you're not a bellhop anymore
you're an air saunter
[Laughter]
congratulations
you're an air saunter you're the first
guy
that got hired as an
as an air saunter
why do you have that shitty hat on
because that's what bellhops wear and
you're an air saunter
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
you're a breeze mingler
dude
[Laughter]
yeah dude
so i get all so he says you know what i
can do and i say
i hope it's good
and he says i'll get you one of these
things and it brings out one of those
big ass clunky things the go go going it
doesn't matter it could be on the
flattest [ __ ]
flattest smoothest [ __ ] surface those
those bag those bell hop [ __ ]
going with the big ass arches right like
it's half of a mcdonald's sign
here i'll give you one of these and you
put the bags on that and bring it to the
room and i say oh you must only have
rooms on the first floor
but the building looks high
so what's up with that
what's up with that oxygen mangler
so i put the things on i got calvin
still on my other bicep because the
oxygen oxygen is draining
so we push it up and we got to push it
up take an elevator in the back it's
weird as [ __ ] dude it looks like this
hotel was based like the one that
resident evil based its [ __ ]
board on
so we get to the thing and we're like
hey
exhausted sweat pouring out of our
armpits calvin's full of diaper [ __ ]
still giggling
and i'm like hey we gotta check in okay
cool hey by the way do you have anybody
that could help uh with the bags
nah
and i say hey why
and he says covet
and i say so we just bring he says well
after like
11 p.m we just we don't have the guys
because it's because of covet so i'm
like all right
so we got to do it so we got to do it so
we get in the hotel we get in the
[ __ ] elevator we're going up with all
the bags we got to pull them all out
dude it's hard as [ __ ] all right and
i'm holding calvin and pushing the thing
and she's got three bags and [ __ ] and we
gotta all the doors are closed you know
when like the magnets don't work and the
doors close and [ __ ] do you know what
i'm talking about
and the and and we have to open the
doors and the mat and everything
clanking around we're dropping bags dude
i'm so pissed right we get into the
[ __ ] thing
and
we we put calvin in the crib and now at
this point he's just like what is the
life like he doesn't he doesn't even
understand where are we why are these
why is this room why is nobody here
just like
it's like [ __ ] 4am for me
and so we put him down
i deadbolt the front
door so no cleaning ladies can come in
and be like
oh baby let's take him or whatever
and uh oh free baby you know and uh
finally my prayers are answered you know
what i mean
um
and so then kristen
shuts
the adjoining room door
on his side
okay
so let's rewind okay let's tell this
story again if you're not all ah
about it at this point okay
i closed the door to calvin's room dead
bolted it
and then kristen closed the adjoining
door on his side
[Music]
all right
so now if there's a fire
oh [ __ ]
and then to this day there would be a
fire okay so i was like no no no
what are you what are you doing and she
said what and i said
i deadbolted the door and she said so
and i said we can't get in there
and i go to kick the door down and she's
like hey stop it let me go down she goes
down to the [ __ ] hey she's she cuz
she's i'm i'm fuming like i'm just so
i'm like oh my god it's gonna be a
[ __ ] what if calvin starts crying and
i gotta [ __ ] i'll break the door i'll
break this [ __ ] door i'll crawl out
do like the naked gun when the place is
on fire and i walk i'll go out the
window i'll [ __ ] go across the
building and into the other window
and if she's gone for like five minutes
she comes back up and she's like it's
fine and i was like what do you mean is
it they're going to bring the guy up
with the tool to do it and i was like oh
really and she's like yeah dude a
[ __ ]
a guy that looks like a little uzi vert
shows up with one of those [ __ ] uh
what what do you call them the [ __ ]
big ass
both cutters they're so it's so big he's
dragging dude it's bigger than the guy
and he's like which door
and i'm like what
this one and he's like cool
opens it up and just [ __ ]
he probably have to like sit on it just
go go
and the [ __ ] ding ding ding ding he's
like hi man
like give me a [ __ ] fist bump and
then just walk away dude the bolt was on
the ground where are we
just [ __ ] now i can't deadbolt the
door hopefully the [ __ ] cleaning lady
doesn't steal my baby
we just it was a broke there's no way
they fixed it fixed it there's no way
they fixed it dude
[ __ ]
this hotel dude do not stay at the union
station hotel in st louis it's awful
it's also in a [ __ ] shitty area dude
it's like just
there's better hotels
what hotel you walk out there's nothing
around dude except for [ __ ] people
playing loud music out of their cars
dude and then
and then
we call enterprise dude this is so long
but i don't give a [ __ ] dude we call
enterprise and we're like hey we never
got our car so what's the deal
you didn't tell us that you guys closed
or whatever the [ __ ] you know no shuttle
and she's like oh well i am so sorry i
said let me talk to the top person
let me talk to the person who is high
you know who i want to talk to right now
chuck enterprise
that's who don't give me this [ __ ]
guy who picks up the phone go fumbling
around hello enterprise this is probably
enterprise don't give me that guy
you know these companies will start at
the [ __ ] person who operates the
phone's wife you gotta talk to him
and she's like i don't really know um
craig you work here
right
let me talk to the person top let me
talk to the top boss of enterprise so
another lady comes on hello oh i am so
sorry to hear never got my car what do
we do to fix it you know what i'ma have
someone call you as soon as they get in
on tuesday because it's a three-day
weekend
[Music]
i'm sitting here friday
right i'm about to [ __ ] put a figure
in my ass just so something else is
happening
so now
i'm like okay and i'm happy because i
know they're not gonna call ever right
and i get to be more mad and i get to
feel justified and they never called yay
enterprise go
[ __ ] yourself enterprise enterprise and
[ __ ] saint in the union station hotel
at st louis go [ __ ] yourselves dude and
then when we go to check out of the
hotel wait what was the thing i got real
mad at
at the end
what was the thing i got real mad at the
end babe
remember the thing at the end
oh the [ __ ] [ __ ] dude the day we
turned i got it the day we the day we we
check out
dude we we get up and we're like you
know calvin sleeps till like nine dude
eight o'clock in the [ __ ] morning the
day we check out checkout is when
checkout is when maybe maybe 11. you can
usually push it till two if you're a
degenerate your boy is a degenerate okay
but we woke up
at 8 30 all right calvin's still
sleeping
but before that before we woke up at 8
knock on calvin's door it's eight it's
eight calvin starts crying i say what
the [ __ ] i open up the door right
because we didn't close it because i
closed it this time and i closed the
right door and calvin's [ __ ] safe and
sound and then that door closes and i'm
like oh the [ __ ] knocking on calvin's
door then on my door
i open up the door and i just i don't
even know who it is and i said you
walked the baby it says
so now i'm so so now i'm just and even
kristen is like
you know they're bad you can you can go
ahead go ahead go ahead born free go
ahead
born free and i just do [ __ ] thunder
[Laughter]
i just do thunder thunder thundercats
give me the phone
[Music]
what the [ __ ] do it again
the third time i called somebody picked
up but but
but hotel
ear
business
was it that one guy that i met at the
[ __ ] beginning when we got there that
night he's running around doing
everything
hello
hi listen
who can i talk to that's
all the way up then and
then
and then
who can i talk to that's all the way up
cause i'm so sick of [ __ ] ki sweat
comes in no money
nobody
nobody's here
at all
nobody but me
so she said well hold on let me get a
manager
that [ __ ] music that always plays
that [ __ ] hold music
it makes you feel like you're in [ __ ]
reno or some [ __ ]
and hi i said dude this [ __ ] excuse
for a hotel and i'm swearing and i don't
ever swear when it comes to customer
service because i don't want them to
have that over on me right i want that i
want to be like the cool calm collected
james bond [ __ ] but [ __ ] that
dude that went out the window and now
i'm a school teacher on her day off you
understand
now i'm a school teacher
on sunday
i'm letting my swear words
fly out dude
thunder thunder thundercats ho
and i say this is what happened and i'm
just [ __ ]
i'm saying it all right
and you got [ __ ] keith's right here
and the [ __ ] thing is happening and
nobody [ __ ] kids sweat and the
[ __ ] i turned into a thundercat you
understand and she said fine and i said
at the end oh and i said what can you do
to make this right and she said well we
could give you free breakfast we're
leaving
we're leaving
why would we want free breakfast from a
[ __ ] by the way
when we checked out
getting the hotel online before we left
included the package was free breakfast
so you're gonna give us free free
breakfast and i said
what the [ __ ] would i want free
breakfast for i already have that [ __ ]
here and she said oh okay sir and i said
i can't oh and she was giving me
attitude and i said i can't i can't
believe i said this i can't wait to
blast you on my podcast
and she said you can do that that's fine
and i hung up dude
lionel and chitara dude
yay they also didn't clean the rooms
they also didn't clean the rooms at all
and i and i [ __ ] asked them about it
and they said we yeah we don't do that
i said why covid guess what saturday and
sunday they had [ __ ] full
weddings that were over 200 guests deep
dude
you can't this is the worst thing that
the hotel actually did you can't
bend covet how you want it to suit your
pockets
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh yeah we won't hire [ __ ] room
cleaning service room service or even a
[ __ ] bellhop after uh
nightfall
but
if you want to pay thousands and
thousands of dollars to host [ __ ]
super spreaders by all means
every day on the weekend sure we don't
care about health we care about pockets
dude
that [ __ ] drove me nutso so [ __ ]
enterprise and [ __ ] that uh
union station hotel in st louis dude
they had a [ __ ] she was like we
booked it because there was an aquarium
for calvin we went to the aquarium they
had like [ __ ] nine stingrays who
gives a [ __ ] i want room service
[ __ ] stingrays i want room service [ __ ]
[ __ ] stingrays i want my bags handled
anyway dude i'm done i talked about that
too long but it was so i needed to dude
because i have therapy and then i have
this podcast which is therapy
i gotta come clean when i was a kid once
i was in kindergarten
and
i like stole
[ __ ] six legos
like literally six of them six lego
pieces i put them in my backpack and at
dinner my mom was looking through my
backpack and she said what's these legos
and i said oh the teacher gave him two
teacher gave him two to me because she
said i was a good student they can cook
on my feet johnny thinks quick on his
feet you know even as a young age
johnny thinks quick on his little feet
she was like really and i said yeah and
she said that is so
nice of her
and i felt it
did i mean it got me it got me right
here it got me right here oh [ __ ] she
believes me
and someone else is getting credit for
being a nice person when it didn't exist
and i was like yep yep yep already in
the lie [ __ ] it i was waist deep let's
do it i said wow that's so cool
later on on the phone i heard my mom say
and would you believe what mrs whatever
the [ __ ] her name is did
i overhear her saying and she gave him
like six or seven legos because he was a
good boy isn't that so sweet i felt it
i felt it right here
i was however old i was and i felt it
right here
i was already [ __ ] tits deep in the
lie
you know
oh [ __ ]
so you know what i did the next day i
quietly went to school
with those legos in my backpack
and i quietly slipped them back
where they belonged
i lied for a day and i made it right and
it never came clean never told my mommy
about that and i'm saying it right now
on this podcast now does she listen to
this podcast no
but you guys are [ __ ] and you'll
probably find her online and dm her that
i stole legos once when i was six so
that's it
i only stole that and a hat once
from
bright aid
and it was green
neon green and white and those are the
only things i stole
and i returned one and the green hat i
stole because i thought
if i put it on my head and walk out and
the cashier doesn't say [ __ ] then i
deserve it and i still kind of think
that actually it was like 11
but i looked him right in the eyes and
they said anything else and i said nope
what the [ __ ]
it is it was [ __ ] like before monster
energy drinks but it looked like that it
was like a green and white zebra hat
like neon green and i looked him with
that [ __ ] hat on and i said nope
that'll be all and he said all right and
i walked out with that hat on i stole it
those are the two things i sold i'm one
of them
[ __ ] man
i want to talk about the funniest
[ __ ] all right there are a few videos
online
i don't know if i'm going to laugh at
this like i did when i first saw this
there are a few videos online
that make me laugh so hard that i just
can't do you know what i mean i it's a
good thing i was laying down in bed
because i would have just crumpled
it
got me so good
i posted it on my story
and it's i think it's from that t hank's
profile which is so funny man t dot
hanks
and uh on instagram and i post it and i
post on my story and this [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude
this made me laugh
so
much
here we go
i'm gonna play it
what the [ __ ] with the lights
chocolate croissant
you only get one so take
okay one
you want to eat two that's good now you
put your bologna finger on it i like
this one no it's just a croissant with
chocolate chips in it
why the [ __ ] are you touching them all i
like this one better they're all the
same no they're not we'll get
[Laughter]
bro when he when he
oh this is so funny okay when he hold on
what the [ __ ] with the lights dude
first of all
he comes in so hot already dude i didn't
realize how he came in until i watched
it about six times he comes in
he goes and he's already
what the [ __ ] with the lights just so
mad already like it's like it's probably
his fault he's probably hitting the
wrong
oh [ __ ] dude okay and he comes in with a
gift for like his daughters you know
they look like they're in college but he
brings a a [ __ ] and he says
he
thinks he's
super dad you know what i mean and he
said
he wants so much credit when he says
when he says
[Laughter]
what he said
croissants dude he wants so much credit
and he he's so
he can't help how mad he is about the
lights you know but he went in with an
idea of oh i'm gonna make
my daughter's day you know what i mean
and so he's
quickly
swallows the anger about the lights and
says chocolate croissants right okay
dude so that i love that already so okay
so so here we go
okay dude so then he opens it up dude by
the way it's already opened like he
already had one you know
[Music]
one of the doctors going mmm and he
opens it up you know you can't open up
those kirkland [ __ ] cellophane
bullshits without being so [ __ ] because
they're always so stuck together you
know like chocolate croissants right and
dude and it has to go
his way do you know what i mean that's
my favorite part about this it has to go
his way he needs to be dulling him out
right he wants to save some for later
whatever he's got in his head
it's deteriorating right now he got
through the first what the [ __ ] is wrong
with the lights happy got through it and
then his daughters just deteriorate him
with their actions dude and it's amazing
dude it's
you only get one so take one
dude i'm making a rule already first of
all there's [ __ ] nine okay there's
literally oh i actually think there's 12
in here okay i can't really see but i
think there's 12 chocolate croissants
and i only get one so dude already set a
rule there's 12 of them you only get one
so just like i hate to break it to you
but like chocolate croissants but also
you only get one okay so that's amazing
right that he's setting the rule and
then immediately daughter comes in
scoops up two with one hand all right
now i can feel this guy's energy dude
and the [ __ ] goes back to them what the
[ __ ] is up with the lights but
twofold
right because he already swallowed that
he probably feels like he was
like being a good person by letting the
light thing slide so now she's taking
two and i just said take one and she
jumped on it too quickly i get this dude
i get him man
okay two you want to eat two that's good
dude okay two you won't eat two that's
good like fuming dude
fuming to say okay good good two get
okay i said one but you get you got to
you won't eat two good dude
fuming i gotta we gotta start it over
dude this is the great [ __ ] you if you
don't like that i'm breaking this video
down and you wish i was doing something
else on this podcast
no this is important this this is what
we need to be talking about dude this
video is absolutely
tragically
unbelievable okay let's start from the
beginning again yes with the lights
chocolate croissants
you only get one so take one
okay two you won't eat two that's good
now you put your baloney finger on it
what does he mean this is so off the
rails i don't even know what he means by
baloney figure there's two things
that he might mean and each of them are
better than the other one all right
there's two things he might mean all
right now
he either means your fingers look like
baloney which is so shitty for a dad to
say all right
or i think i like this one better
dude i think i like this one better dude
they ate baloney before this
and he doesn't want the taste of baloney
on his croissants he might eat later
dude
i hope it's that dude
this is the greatest all right dude
let's start it over man [ __ ] off
what the [ __ ] is wrong with the lights
dude he's so bad they're just watching a
show you know
they're just watching a show this guy
comes in like a [ __ ] hurricane dude
and with chocolate like a chocolate
casserole hurricane dude holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] man
oh [ __ ]
you guys started over we gotta watch the
whole thing through dude
what the [ __ ] with the lights
chocolate croissants
you only get one so take one
okay two
you want to eat two that's good now you
put your baloney finger on it i like
this one no it's just a croissant with
chocolate chips in it
why the [ __ ] are you touching them all
right i like this one better they're all
the same no they're not
we'll get it
[ __ ] off
he says [ __ ] up he says [ __ ] up because
the daughter [ __ ] touched more than
she should have been take some plea
this guy dude i'm watching this in the
bed the first you think i'm leaving hard
now the first time i saw this i was
crying dude tears were coming up i was
rolling and rolling around and kristen
said she said i was laughing so much
dude i laughed myself to sleep the next
morning she woke up to the bed shaking
because i was thinking about
it's not a joke dude she woke up because
the bed was shaking because i was
[ __ ] woke up thinking
well you got your balance
[Music]
dude okay so so [ __ ] [ __ ] man
but when i was watching it she says you
know what you think this is so funny and
i said why and she said because he
is you dude
and it made so much sense because i
agree with this guy i agree that this
guy got the chocolate croissants and he
needed it should have went his way he
was nice enough to bring the [ __ ]
chocolate croissants in for his [ __ ]
family and they were touching them all
and doing them how he didn't want to
they ate baloney beforehand and made the
[ __ ] chocolate flavor baloney shits
and the lights didn't work this guy was
being so nice bringing his family 12
croissants and his daughter came in just
like
they're touching them all with bologna
fingers dude
[ __ ] up the lights and he pays the
light bill
but in that something man that's just
how life is
i thought about this clip a lot after
this
and that's just how life is you think
you walk into a room whatever that room
is and you got the [ __ ] chunk of
croissants
and the people in there
they don't give a [ __ ] about how you
feel about your chocolate croissants
you know when you start a conversation
with somebody and you're in the car and
you're like when i see this [ __ ]
i'm gonna say this and then they're
gonna say this and then i'm gonna say
that to that
and then you get there and you're like
hey i gotta talk to you about something
and they're on the phone and they're
like hold on one second and you're like
okay well wait this is not something i
prepare for life comes at ya dude
everyone's not going to feel
the same way you do about your chocolate
croissants
and this video is the funniest that's
why
this video is one of the funniest videos
ever because that's what everybody's
doing when they go and they walk into a
party or they walk into an establishment
or they walk home or they [ __ ] get
into their new car or whatever the [ __ ]
it is you're walking in there with some
chocolate croissants
but there are other people in there
and they don't feel that way about your
[ __ ] chocolate croissants how [ __ ]
they want to put their heads all over
the [ __ ] chocolate croissants
and the lights are all [ __ ] up anyway
anywhere when you walk in it just it
doesn't go
the way you think it is and that's it
dude
that's all i want to [ __ ] say dude
for [ __ ] sake this video still made me
laugh out loud
all right
i will say
we got new merch
we got new merch and it's
make friends
in the comments
uh
and it's awesome and it's right here
we're putting it on the screen and it's
just so great man it's my favorite merch
to date you can go chrisleya.com and get
that merch and uh and it's on dude and
that's what's up and it's uh
and it's uh and it's great so you can go
get that merch chrysalia.com
uh make friends and comments and it is
limited patreon got it first if you want
to sign up for a patreon you get
extra episode a month whatever and all
the other [ __ ] and you get uh
first dibs on a lot of merch uh
patreon.com
but i don't want to end the episode yet
i want to say something about norm
mcdonald um because i didn't do it
online
i didn't know if it was my place or not
but i feel like this podcast is you know
anything goes um i met him once
uh and i was struck how nice he was
um
just we didn't even introduce each other
to each other but he was just talking to
me like we already knew each other and i
love guys like that i love guys
that just are already talking to you
like they know you and it made me feel
very comfortable
and i looked i looked up to him and i
still do you know he's passed and um it
was a shock to the comedy world nobody
knew really that he was uh
struggling with cancer and he you know
he eventually lost a battle but i look
at it like he beat it for nine years uh
because uh you know people don't do that
but the guy was truly funny he was a
kind you know he was a comics comics he
was a comics comic but he was one of
those comics comic that just breaks
through to also the [ __ ]
uh the citizens and make them laugh just
as much i mean the guy was just so
special and it wasn't
what
it was like he had this rare mix of how
of the things he said were funny
and then also the way he said it was
funny but also the moments in between
when he was saying words
he made funny somehow and it was like
the pinnacle of of of of a stand-up
comedian it was like it was it was the
words the way you say it and then
sometimes you found yourself watching
nor macdonald
laughing
at the pauses
because of how absurd what he just said
was or
how or you couldn't wait what he was
going to say next or
just why did he pause
this way now
he just was a true comic
and he was one of those guys that just
had to be a comic you know and thank god
he chose to do stand-up because he was
great i think he was one of the best to
ever do it and you know the other day we
lost
a legend um
and
you know it's weird man the times that
we're going through now and how
everything's so weird and people are
dying and
life is hard
i don't know things like that hit me
differently now um
and it makes me want to appreciate
all the stuff that
um he did you know uh
i i went back and i watched some of the
stuff that just on youtube and but yeah
i think it's important to appreci
appreciate norm mcdonald um and he is
he is great and he was great and he made
me feel like i knew him and i
appreciated that because i've always
looked up to him so norm macdonald rest
in peace and uh thanks for all you did
and all the laughs um and that's what
we'll end the podcast on what's up you
guys that's it for this episode of
congratulations if you want to
listen or watch the rest of the episode
go to my patreon which is
patreon.comcrystalia
and uh you get the rest of the uh
episode a lot of episodes are
15 10 15 20 minutes longer
and you get all that footage uh that you
get to if you sign for a patreon and
then also there's an extra episode a
month there's also another
segment i do called review mode and i
post behind the scenes stuff i also have
other stuff there's another episode of
with chris that i didn't post on the
more crystallia youtube channel but
anyway guys uh you get first dibs on
merch a lot of stuff so go on over to
chrissalia.com
patreon.com and check it on out and if
not we appreciate you anyway thanks for
uh thanks for checking us out on youtube
bye guys
[Music]
[Laughter]
congratulations
[Music]
thank you